mine is about to kill a mockingbirds you
know Aaron Sorkin's to kill a
mockingbirds been a huge hit on Broadway
now the cast is ready to take it to
where Madison Square Garden for who
students first on CBS this morning we're
very excited to announce 18,000 New York
City public school students are getting
invites to see this hit show for free
February 26 2020 the production will
take place at Madison Square Garden now
this will be the first ever Broadway
show to perform in the world famous
venue that's a very big deal to kill a
mockingbirds based on Harper Lee's
classic novel holds the title of the
most successful American play in
Broadway history producer Scott Rudin
and Barry Diller said okay we'd like to
do this and now when they speak stuff
happens so it's going to be at Madison
Square Garden but it's huge you know it
opened in 2018 December 2018 has been
sold out every night ever since so for
the kids to get to see this for free
Madison Square Garden never been done
that's a big deal staging challenge is
huge